just like you when your jaw dropped like
I my jaw dropped when I realized they
pulled off this Blind Side like walk me
through that Tribal Council what was
going through your head as Jeff was
reading those votes
I mean
um so I mean it sucks
I was so I
what was going through my head was like
I I felt like everybody was being a
little bit too comfortable with with
just sitting there and I was like you
know something doesn't seem right at the
last minute obviously it was too late
for me to even do anything something
doesn't seem right
um but hey you know what they
I I felt like I was at the point of
feeling dark because from the very
beginning I was on the bottom uh coming
into the competition and I came in as
the alternate and then messing up the
first challenge as well like pretty much
landed me on the bottom from day one so
I I was doing everything I could just to
stay another day
um so I just wanted to make it one more
day so I can make it to the merch
and then like next week was the merge I
was like no oh I know
that's insane so you had no idea then
that this was going on behind the scenes
like at Camp there was nothing that kind
of like maybe slightly tipped you off
um I could I didn't have time because I
went on a journey I went on a journey by
the time I came back I only had time to
to share my advantage with uh Carla and
I couldn't really talk to anybody else
about anything else or try to defend and
tell them hey you know what we should do
this or that but no like the next thing
you know it was time for us to go to
Tribal Council and it was hard for me to
try to like do anything at that point it
was pretty much just like from what I
was told I'm so sorry my dog has been
working oh no worries from what I was so
sorry
um from what I from what I was told I
was it wasn't me that night and I had to
trust the people that I was working with
so that's what makes it very difficult
is that
um I had to trust Carla I had to trust
Ryan so yeah you have to trust someone
uh and um and if you don't want to over
ask you don't want to say too much you
don't want to say anything at that point
because you're like if I say the wrong
thing they might change their mind and
blow me out so this the game of Survivor
is a very very interesting game because
you're only playing the game with
whatever little bit of knowledge that
you have and meanwhile everybody else
when they're watching they already know
everything that's going down so that's
what makes it difficult for us and so
but it's I enjoyed every second of it I
enjoy people coming for me and trying to
take me out from day one I enjoy Lindsay
trying to take me out from day one and
and I know it sucks but that was the
game that was part of the game and
I stay there and defend my name as much
as brothel
kudos to them that's a great Outlook to
have you know
um so you know you shared your
knowledge's power Advantage with Carla
and then she was the one who was part of
voting you out do you feel a little bit
betrayed by her yes so a lot of things
that people didn't get to see Carla and
I had a very good relationship or at
least I thought we did
um we uh she came up to me from day one
and she was like you're lgbtq I'm lgbtq
you're Latino I'm Latino and although I
didn't want to go into the game just
playing the game saying that you know
like uh playing with someone just
because of the race or their sexuality
uh you know I felt comfortable around
her because she understood me and and in
levels that a lot of people wouldn't
understand me so for me yeah like I
really trusted her even though
there were certain things that were kind
of like I was able to tell that she
might have been lying to me from
different different days uh I really
wanted to trust her and at that point it
was just Ryan and I so I needed to trust
someone you know so she had to be my
like did he had to be the third vote on
anything that we did so that's just how
I went down and she played a good game
she's killing it uh same thing with
Cassidy regardless of whatever arguments
or differences that we had you know
they're still there maybe that's some
maybe I should have done something that
they did so that way I can stay there
oh my gosh well talking about your other
Alliance member Ryan he was also
blindsided by this Blind Side just as
shocked as you were so do you think he
has a chance in this merge now because
he's kind of at the bottom of the cocoa
tribe yeah he is but luckily
um luckily he uh he the merch is here so
now at least he can talk to people and
try to figure something out that was my
goal I just wanted to make it to the
merge so that way I can like I I won't
be as scared anymore to play the game
because you know being uh in a try where
everybody depends on you to do good or a
challenge you know like me being in the
bottom I was pretty scared so and now
with him hopefully he can you know like
uh talk to the right people and and and
find new friends uh or new people to
work with so that way he can you know
stay there longer because it would have
been crazy now he went from thinking he
was on the top as well all the way to
the bottom so yeah yeah play out yeah so
we'll gonna have to watch and see what
happens exactly so let's go back quickly
to your journey that you went on with
Jesse and Janine was there ever a moment
where you were like no I'm not gonna
risk my vote I'm gonna play it safe or
were you set on no like this is Survivor
I'm gonna risk my vote and see what
happens
I went there I went to the to the to the
journey with a mission I said the the
the merch is right around the corner and
we have two tribes working against us we
have to do whatever we need to do to to
be able to fight back because at this
point it's like we have to give her at
all to be able to protect ourselves so
the way I saw it I didn't see it as a me
thing I saw it as a us thing like I want
to protect cocoa tribe I want to protect
our my alliance and and when I say my
alliance I mean meet Carla and Ryan and
James so uh Cassidy in my mind Cassidy
was supposed to be going home that night
so I just wanted to protect the people
that I was working with so Coco can make
it all the way to the end
um but uh that was the mission and
that's why I was willing to risk it no
matter what and that's why I even went
in and lied about say well I I thought I
was lying I was like
all right about
or telling them that I was gonna go home
tonight if I if I didn't get something
um
but yeah but you know they still risk
their roads and thankfully I mean
luckily I wanted at least I got I got it
that dream come true for me you know I
was the happiest person I was like this
is why I came to Survivor and now it's
my chance to show my tribe that I can
protect them too and once the merch
comes I can show them that I can protect
them and I'm gonna fight for them
yeah well unfortunately you left with
the advantage in your pocket did you at
least keep it as a souvenir please tell
me you still have it
well they take that away from us it goes
back into the game yes I don't know
usually that's what they do I think I
don't know you know like I know if you
watched previous Seasons yeah if if
somebody goes home with an idol like
then there's another Idol somewhere so I
don't know that that's that's why my
mentality is behind that and so well
maybe one day you'll be able to get it
back because I feel like you deserve to
have that oh I hope so that was my that
was a dream come true if not I'm gonna
have to create a new one and just frame
it somewhere and be like yeah that was
the advantage right there I'm gonna
start telling people that I do have it
absolutely
so to kind of wrap this all up like
obviously we know you didn't make it to
final three but you know you talked
about how much it meant to you to find
this advantage and it was a dream come
true was your Survivor Journey the one
that played out everything that you
hoped it would be
I left the game having no regrets I left
the game um when I was playing the game
I kept on telling myself play the game
like it's your second time playing I
heard Jeff saying that a while back and
I was like I have to if I walk past a
tree I was like let me climb this tree
really fast maybe there's an idol there
if I saw a weird sewn let me flip the
stone and see if there's an idol there
if I saw a coconut let me open this
coconut let's see so I have no regrets
whatever happen in the island it may
sense at that moment if I didn't say
enough it was because maybe I felt like
I was safe and to me it may sense at
that moment
um and and the relationships that I have
from playing the game I'm grateful for
that uh the the amount of people that
contacted me to social media people
saying thank you for opening up and for
sharing your story like I'm grateful for
that and I'm happy that he touched
someone and if he helps somebody out
there you know that makes me really
happy so at the end of the day this is a
once in a lifetime opportunity I got to
play the game I was an alternator I
wasn't even supposed to be on the show
and I made it to the show so for me this
is a dream come true and I know I wish I
would have stayed there longer but I did
something that so many people are trying
to do and it's hard to do you know so
many people have been applying and it's
hard for them to to make it so I'm
grateful for absolutely everything and I
don't regret anything that's an amazing
Outlook to have and lastly I just want
to touch on this because I think it's
really important like you said you were
sharing your story for the lgbtq plus
Community the lgbtq plus Latina
community so what does it mean to you to
be able to represent that on survive on
a platform like Survivor
um it was kind of scary for me at first
because I didn't wanna I didn't want to
say much about my family because I
didn't want people to look at my family
like you know in a negative way because
they haven't spoken to me in 17 years uh
but at the same time I still love them
you know and
maybe someday they'll come around I
don't know but um but I also wanted to
show the world that people like me do
exist and you know there's people out
there that I might be struggling with
their sexuality right now people that
are going through being homeless or that
they feel like they don't have anything
out there but look at me I I made it and
and I've gone through that I've gone
through depression I've gone through
wanting to give up in life and I'm here
and I made it to the show and this could
be anybody out there so just don't let
your fears and don't let your
insecurities get in the way of your your
dreams and that's ultimately the message
that I wanted to send everyone out there
that can relate to someone like me
I love that well it was a pleasure
watching you on the show I'm so sad to
see you go but both you and I were going
to be watching the rest of the season
gonna see what's gonna happen but thank
you so much for sharing your story thank
you so much for the time with me
um thank you so much thank you so much
for having me I appreciate it I feel
like I'm a win at our hearts oh I love
that well I'm glad we could be a part of
that so thank you so much